When I first got into education a
quarter-century ago, it was frighteningly
easy to find teachers and schools who
shrugged off responsibility for kids who
weren't learning. It was too easy to
blame the home or the family. Happily,
things have changed. Today, when you go to
schools and systems, you find teachers
being asked to take responsibility for
every one of their charges. That's a
fantastic thing. Here's the problem:
Teachers don't work alone. They work in
partnership with families; with students.
We need to make sure that teachers are
not being asked to shoulder the whole
burden. The KIPP charter schools have a
wonderful model of how to deal with this:
They have a Commitment to Excellence
that is signed by teacher, student, and
parent, in which they are all asked to take
responsibility for making sure the
student succeeds. What we need are
schools where teachers are asked to do
all that they can for every child, but
that also expects parents and families to
step up and be partners for the schools,
to ensure that each child is well served.
To learn more about my take on school reform, check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like a AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.